hello this is gabriel from bentorosa.com  here from vancouver bc today's one  minute monday is there's something in  your life that you don't like change it  now you want to see change in your life  you need to start taking action today i  was working on a job that i was not  happy in it was a wine store and i saw  this product that i knew i could make  better so that night i went home and i  started making drawings and i started  taking my first step towards my goal  that goal wasn't a goal of success or of  money it was a goal of change since then  i made prototypes i went into production  and today we've sold over 1500 aerators  i believe  if you want the real goods i share my  best advice for entrepreneurs every week  in my newsletter click the link below to  check it out it's free  hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of  riseonline.com and i want to say evan  carmichael's newsletter is consistent  fun  inspiring and it's the only newsletter i  prioritize and look forward to period